hello folks I hope I'm I'm online
YouTube changed a lot of things this
time around it went to a new mode and I
have to learn a little bit of this so I
don't even know if I'm online yet I hope
I am okay let's see if I can read here
if anybody can hear me and save me
please put a comment okay I love it yeah
I know that I'm online okay
I'll assume until I see a comment there
that I'm online okay anyways I'm gonna
start today with a couple comments okay
and here's the first comment again if
you can put a comment can you hear me
can you see me my six of mine can you
see me I hope you can because they
changed everything in YouTube okay thank
you thank you because I have no way of
telling right now until I learned this a
little better
you know how this is working out anyways
I'm going to start with a couple
comments okay and your that I thought
were quite interesting and so I want to
address those issues and so here's the
first one okay
it's fall says objects that exists
require location but doesn't location
require that the objects exists in other
words he's suggesting there's a circular
argument or a circular set of
definitions that's that's what he's
insinuating right otherwise how would
you have distance if the objects didn't
exist this would make your definition of
exist circular if location requires
existence okay I think it's a good
question good question to answer and I
do want to answer this okay here it is
I'll put it side-by-side man
and here's the answer my answer is that
we have to define things in the proper
order
in science in rational science right we
must define in a certain order first we
must define the word object obviously
then we have to define location before
distance motion before location or
object concept before object and exist
before location or object it has to be
in that order okay and there you see the
rational order object noting as its
opposite first distance followed by
location and then only then can you
define motion exist in concept so the
issue is you have to define in the
proper order otherwise you know you're
gonna get you know you can't define
location until you define object and you
can't define exists until you define
location you can't say well but location
means that the object exists now because
that's not what the definition of
location is the definition of location
is the set of distances okay we do not
make allusion to any word that we're
gonna define later that's why it's very
carefully structured so that you go step
by step in a logical rational manner we
do object in object why because physics
cannot be done without an object so the
first principle like what I call the
golden principle of physics is that you
must have an object to do physics so the
first word you got to define is the word
object we define as that which has shape
we do not have to define shape okay and
that's a long story but just very easily
synthetically we don't have to define
shape because shape is one of the
criteria is is one of many criteria that
you can use to define object you can use
C touch mass volume subject of a
sentence now there's a lot of
definitions that you can use for the
word object the one we have to use for
physics is the word shape do we have to
know what shape is know we have to know
the difference between shape and motion
we have to know the difference between
shape and touch
between shape and see we have to know
that difference but for those who don't
know what shape is go to a kindergarten
and ask the kitchen children you know
shoma here I show my ball in a cube okay
Oh same material same weight same
everything even color or whatever and
say what is the difference and I'll tell
you that the difference is shaped so if
you don't know what shape is go to a
kindergarten dad LTG you must have
missed that class when you were a kid
okay okay another comment was made also
I thought it was interesting says does
the RSM regard words like quick slow
right to be adverbs rather than
adjectives because they describe dynamic
action motion of objects rather than
static properties yeah we have to be
aware be aware that if you use the word
quick or slow fast I don't know all
those words in ordinary speech they're
known as adjectives okay why because
they describe or modify or qualify the
subject of the sentence use the a you
know they qualify a mountain and you can
use the word motion the word orbit the
word itinerary the board word projectory
as a noun in ordinary speech not so in
physics and physics all those words are
verbs okay motion is verb itinerary is
verb its motion dynamic concept and so
when you use like quick or slow or fast
or whatever what you're doing is
qualifying what you're your qualifying
motion and so the way we look at that in
physics we look at the value of that you
know what does it really mean and what
it means is you know you have a verb and
you have this so called adjective that's
qualifying a verb now it's an advert for
us these words are adverbs and the best
way to see this is to turn it around and
say moving quickly then it becomes an
adverb immediately you know orbiting
slow
Lee okay and then then you turn the
adjectives into an adverb and that's the
way you have to look at this okay okay
what am I going to talk about today just
those two comments which I thought had
to be addressed really interesting
comments and I thought they needed to be
clarified okay I'm gonna talk today
about whether time exists does time
exists and for this I'm gonna start at
the end
okay well start at the end and for a
good reason because I'm gonna end at the
beginning kind of like you know we're
gonna work our way backwards today I
hope you can bear with me today okay so
where do I start well as you know for
the last twenty years I've been peddling
a theory saying that we were the last
humans on earth okay last generation of
humans on earth and so what's part of
that well this week I read an article
that's about it we gold now and here it
is let me put this up here and this
article says the following just a couple
of lines that I pulled out of there says
during the coronavirus by the way 22
million americans have filed for
unemployment benefits in the last four
weeks okay so lots of people unemployed
okay it says during the corona virus
pandemic layoffs initially hit service
jobs the hardest workers at retailers
restaurants and hotels for example were
among the first to lose their jobs
now as deep economic downturn takes hold
job losses could start to hit white
collar office jobs too I thought those
were service jobs as well okay a
shutdown shutdowns continued job losses
will likely extend into other areas of
the labor market such as business and
professional services again services so
what's wrong with all this well what's
wrong with it is that the people who
lost their jobs are I'd say
like 100% service people in some way or
another
what would have happened if agricultural
workers would have lost their jobs like
you know 20 million agricultural workers
lose their jobs that method there's been
that Betty but I mean what if they all
lost their jobs that went well that's a
little different than service jobs so
what this article shows is that server
jobs don't affect anything because
service is abstraction and so here we
lost 22 million jobs or maybe more by
now right and it didn't make a dent in
in our lives if most of our lives you
know I mean we have to stay inside doors
where mass that kind of thing yeah
there's been changes but what I'm saying
is those 22 million people they're laid
off it's like okay so it didn't affect
us at all but if 22 million agricultural
workers would have lost their job you of
all of them were lost their jobs would
be in a little bit of a problem and this
tells you something about services
services are not needed well we need it
as agriculture we need food we don't
need services and here you have so many
people you know unemployed and you know
the it didn't affect the majority of us
out there okay we still can do our
things more or less a lot of people have
to work from home etc etc but what I'm
saying those two there's 22 million
people it's like you know we put them
out of work and then no problem we'll
just give them some money and they go to
the unemployment office they have this
unemployment insurance and it's like
yeah so what no problem so you see an
idea I and I like to use that analogy
you know you have the eyes of God and
you're up there looking at Earth from up
there right and what do you see well
what you see is with what we built what
what is tangible with what it exists and
what exists are you know the building's
the the highways the houses the the
fields of corn
everything that you can see what you
don't see are the services because
services are all promises are all
abstractions so what am I getting - I'm
saying that these twenty two million
people were already unemployed anyone
who is in serve in the service industry
is already unemployed services
unemployment okay
there's some noise there okay
and so here's the breakdown for the
United States for example you know and
you can see how many people are
unemployed says services eighty percent
in 2017 it's gotta be about the same
thing today so that's how many
unemployed people there are really
because anyone who's in services is
really not producing anything and we
prove that you can say evidence to
convince the converted recruit by
showing that we can get rid of twenty
two million jobs and you know the world
keeps turning no problem okay so
whatever they produced didn't affect us
at all you can get another idea from the
following you know I mean you may want
to go to a restaurant and have someone
serve you you know so there's a cook
that cooks the food there's a waiter who
brings the food over do you need that
well no you could stay at home eat at
home right so you don't need to go to a
restaurant and you don't need to go to
another hotel except if you know you're
maybe on these are yeah some businessmen
must travel from city to city but I'm
talking about the people who go on
tourism right do they do we need hotels
no the guy can stay at home he doesn't
need that it's a it's a nice to have
it's a leisure society the the service
society we're all pharaohs you know you
want to build a pyramid you have all
these slaves and you give them a little
bit affording they build you the pyramid
and today is very similar you know you
you don't know how to fix the plumbing
we call the plumber your trustees down
you call the electrician you need to fix
something outside you know in your yard
you call the landscaper or whatever
so you know you pay pay pay everybody
does you they're all everybody's your
servant all you have to do is have money
so it's a it's a leisure society it's a
society where you don't have to be an
expert at anything see this is a little
different than what happened in the
upper Palaeolithic there there were no
middlemen no salesmen you know no people
you could count on yeah you have to go
with your own spear and get your own
master done or is it mammoth okay
there was no middleman says let no
stay-at-home Joe don't worry stay in
your cave I'll go get it for you guy
brings the you know the master that says
there it is give me to bear furs and
your wife all exchanging and that could
have been a good deal for some people
yeah but it never happened never
happened no forget it
no middlemen in those days but today we
rely on everything on middleman and what
do they put into the circle they put
cost middlemen are just cost they're not
they're just an extra cost in in the
whole whole chain of you know getting a
product to you so you know all these
people they're really not doing anything
they're unemployed because if you can do
something yourself and you don't need
them well you can see that you know the
guy was redundant anyways that's my take
I'm sure the anarcho-capitalist will
beat me up on that all the freedomain
Ian's although if I'm misses all these
people will beat me up but I'm just
giving you my five cents worth on that
okay anyways why am i bringing that up
what's that got to do with anything
especially with the subject matter of
today today we're going to talk about
the existence of time and here I'm
bringing extinction okay I started at
the NS we're tourists the beginning
let's start a little bit on the
beginning bring it back to where we were
a couple weeks one week ago I think okay
here we have Aristotle
and so he has this idea about time right
he's gonna work his reasoning here with
time and he says look the infinite
exists okay and so time is infinite so
the question is this time exists so he
says
belief in the existence of the infinite
comes mainly from five considerations
the first one he mentions in that list
is from the nature of time for it is
infinite and so yes the question is
that's time belong to the class of
things that exist or to that of things
that do not exist now it's an
interesting that he uses the word things
because this is where the problem is no
one's ever defined the word thing in the
last 10,000 years and so we have a
problem because he's treating time as a
thing okay and so that's where the
duality comes in where time is a concept
and also an object uses as both that's
what's gonna happen here okay so keep
that in mind yeah yeah so he says the
following he says he continues he says
give me a second here says none can
exist independent except substance okay
except substance that means only
substance can exist which is pretty much
in line with my definition so I have no
problem with that
except that yes I know what he said
there he said it but he it didn't click
in his head okay well you're gonna see
this in a little while okay for
everything is predicated of substance s
subject love it because that's correct
the why did you use that why did you
follow up on that why didn't he realize
how important that statement was though
Steve statements were okay to define the
infinite you must use quantity in other
words you you can't apply it to
substance and he says in your formula
but not substance or quality he says
that he says you you can't apply it to
things even though he's not you gonna
use the words things he's gonna use the
word body or substance when he refers to
thing and he's gonna use thing very
generically to include concepts and
objects and that's where the problem is
because time is a thing and so the
question is time a body a substance or
is by the time of a concept what kind of
thing is it and it's where you use the
word thing and you apply and you begin
to analyze the word thing that you get
it messy because he's never defined
thing he's just defined substance and
body okay this is what we're gonna have
a problem okay so you can tell you the
infant is in the category of quantity
whereas substance or quality cannot be
infinite okay so you're making it clear
you know you can't have a substance that
is infinite you can't have a I won't use
the word thing because he does use the
word thing you can't have a body that is
infinite okay that's what he's saying
here okay so these he realize that much
and what he has in mind what you gotta
keep in mind also he's referring to the
universe if you treat it as a thing as a
body as a substance the universe and
people use it every day they talk about
space and universe as being things as
being bodies as being substances made of
particles the ether and the question is
is that thingy infinite or is it finite
okay that's more or less what he's
getting to here okay and then he he
defines the word object body in this
case he says if bounded by a surface is
if bounded by a surface is the
definition of body there cannot be an
infinite body either intelligible or
sensible you can't even imagine it you
can't touch it okay so he's got the
right idea he says look there's nobody
that is infinite love it okay because
what and a body is that which has shape
and there is no such thing as an
infinite shape because that's not a
shape okay so we got a problem with
infinite chain it's an infinite finite
the what the guy is saying when he does
that
okay so where does he go from here well
yeah he keeps going in his reasoning and
he says the following
he says the theory that the void exists
look at how he handles this through void
okay this this is interesting he says
because he says that the void exists
what is the void void is what you leave
behind when you remove an object so when
the object is in the void we're gonna
call it place according to Aristotle
when you remove the object it's no
longer a place now you left the void
okay that's the notion he's gonna put in
here he says the theory that the void
exists involves the existence of place
for one would define void as place
bereft of body
okay so a void is a place that has
nobody when you put the body in the void
now it's called the place got it okay so
it's a hole in space because space is
also something different according to
them okay if void a place are infinite
okay there must be an infinite body -
okay this is his reasoning if it is
impossible that there should be an
infinite place and is if everybody is in
eighth place
there cannot be an infinite body so his
reasoning is the hole in which the the
rock was when you pull it out that was a
place you when you pull the rock out you
left a hole we would call a void and
neither the void nor the place when the
rock was in there can be infinite
because then there would also be an
infinite rock okay that's his reasoning
essentially I D other hand to suppose
that the infinite does not exist needs
obviously to and I put a little circle
around this just so you see it we're
sorry or a rectangle just so you see
where I'm heading in today many
impossible consequences there will be a
beginning and an end of time let me
repeat that there will be a beginning
and an end of time so that's if we to
suppose that the infinite does not exist
okay so that's how he's gonna relate
time to infinity okay and he's gonna
harp on that
issue okay so here we continue with Ares
analysis and he says a thing is infinite
either by addition or by division in
other words if you take I don't know a
ruler just to look at something more or
less straight you chop it into pieces
you keep chopping chopping chopping
chopping always in half always in half
always in half but at some point you
won't be able to chop it with a knife
because the your knife will be bigger
than what you're trying to chop that's
that's the big problem the accelerators
have supposedly right but you can still
conceptualize chopping it in half in
half in half and half forever and he
calls that infinity that's infinity by
division at the same time you can add
ruler through your ruler or inches or
whatever to your ruler eternally right
forever
and that's infinity by addition so he
says those are the two notions of
infinity that he's got or that he's
proposing the only problem with that
neither one of those we look first to a
body okay we're not saying that one body
is infinite in extent okay that's not
the notion because that's the notion of
infinity and if you want to apply it in
physics you have to say it well is there
an infinite object what do you mean by
that do you mean that you can chop it up
infinitely no does it mean that you can
add more stuff to it infinitely no it
means that the body is extended
infinitely that's the notion of physics
here he's introducing mathematics and
that's again this issue where he uses
the word thing and he's gonna apply this
notion to time why because time can be
chopped into little pieces and you can
have more seconds and hours to time okay
and again the question is whether time
is a thing are we talking about time
being expanding be cut beyond the
surface of space-time or whatever right
into the 50:26 dimension time indeed and
movement are infinite so keep that in
mind he saying these are
finit and again he what was the question
before he says whether there is a
beginning and end of time and he said
they're infinite so it would be
ridiculous to say there's a beginning
and an end of time okay that's the issue
today okay from where does he take us
from there in his reasoning he says well
he kind of summarizes the different
attributes that time has he says time is
infinite time is continuous measure of
motion time is number but time is not is
time is not motion time is number of
motion it's mathematics applied to
motion okay so it's not just I moved I
displaced myself from here to there
no it's putting some numbers to that
that's what he calls time or that's how
he's gonna the notion he's got of time
okay okay and so what does he conclude
after all this well he said he ends up
concluding little hurry
he said if I can get this thing okay so
as time is a measure of motion and of
being moved will time then fail surely
not if motion always exists so as long
as motion exists time exists okay so you
know where to exist kay if time time is
the nature of all change to alter things
from their former condition things
change right in time all things come
into being and pass away okay there's a
beginning and end to all this time time
continues but the thing is what has a
beginning an end okay but time always is
eternal right for which reason some
called it the wisest of all things again
using the word thing to qualify time
what does he concluding says we have
stated them that time exists so what is
areas conclusion he says yeah time does
exist why well because you know it's the
beginning and end of things
things have beginning and ends they come
into being they go out of being or
expire whatever but I'm merely arose
along okay okay
so what do we have to say about all this
well the first problem is that every
never defined a word exists or the word
object thing right very precisely
scientifically in a way that he can use
it consistently that's what that's where
his problem is his book his entire book
becomes nonsense
his whole book becomes total nonsense
his analysis is is worthless because he
doesn't define the two words he needs to
make his case the word object Nord
exists okay so that's where we start
start there to compare ourselves against
Aristotle here show us show how we're a
little different than these folks and so
what you find physically exists that's
physical presence what is physical
presence well the physical stands for
object and present stands for location
okay what is an object that which I
shaved
what is presence the set of distances
that's that's what location is and what
is distance separation between objects
we do not use the census vision to
determine if something exists we don't
touch things to make sure they exist no
no you know air we can probably touch
but we cannot see so you can't determine
that air you can't say air does not
exist because I can't see it for example
right and that's the point we don't use
the senses this is a question of
definitions you have to define what you
mean by exist then you can eat then you
can use the word right now Airy hasn't
defined the word exists he doesn't know
what he's saying every time he says it
exists so you can say that time exists
he can say that a rock exists he can say
that anything exists because he hasn't
defined the word thing and you need the
word thing to talk about existence
because
concepts cannot exist for the purposes
of physics and that's where we have a
difference from the ordinary speech and
mathematical physics where they use the
word exist constantly but they're
referring in many cases to concepts you
cannot use that in physics you cannot
say love exists not in physics you can
do that in ordinary speech and poetry
and mathematical physics you cannot say
that love exists in physics therefore
you cannot say that energy
you cannot say that field exists you
cannot say that mass exists those are
concepts you now see that wave exists
all those are concepts and people don't
realize they're dealing with concepts
and that's why we have to define the
word object in concept before we begin
to debate before we give our
dissertations because unless you define
those words you're going to be chasing
your tail around forever you can't use
words such as energy mass field or wave
those primarily charge as well you can't
use any of those words in physics
because they're concepts you can't treat
them as objects and say you're going to
move a charge around no such monster in
physics okay so until you understand
that you you first you're in the wrong
channel and second you won't be doing
rational so you won't be doing anything
rationally okay you're just gonna be
doing mathematics and that's that's
where we start
okay so where does this take us as far
as the definition of motion and time
well here we have the list we already
defined object as that which has shape
okay
it's not that which has mass not that
which has volume not that which you can
touch not that which you can see it's
that which has shape okay all objects in
the universe with the word object okay
and the dictionary the only commonality
the universal property the universal
attribute of all objects have is shape
that doesn't have shape but doesn't it's
not an object and every order the
dictionary can be be divided into these
two categories either it's an object or
a concept concept is really that which
doesn't have shape that's not the
definition but that's a good rule of
thumb if it has shape object if it
doesn't have shape you put in the
concept pile so just take any word in
the dictionary you can fit into one of
those two categories okay energy does it
have shape no concept field does it have
shape no concept okay if some people
think field has shape now it's got to be
a stand alone object there is no such
thing as field without the magnet people
don't realize this you can I can't bring
a field alone to the
conference room I have to bring the bank
NIT and then the field comes with it
behind okay okay so we define distance
separation between two objects
straightforward do we measure no we
don't measure anything we don't use
numbers we don't use equations all we
have to do is there's a separation
between two objects yeah okay we call
that distance it's a qualitative notion
only strictly location set of distances
from one object to all the other objects
in the universe that's the location of
that asteroid with respect to Jupiter
with respect to the Andromeda galaxy
with respect to Alpha Centauri the
nearest three star system etc so that's
location according to mother nature
there's no frame of reference as in
mathematics you know we don't hammer a
stake in the middle of space and say oh
this is going to be our corner and we're
gonna measure everything from here
now that's mathematics in in the
universe we don't care about measurement
Mother Nature doesn't use that mother
nature simply you know has motion there
of objects that's it her world is very
very simple she never went to school she
never went to college she'd never
learned calculus okay equations or
whatever motion two or more locations
see we go step by step down the line
okay and time well time we don't use it
in science that's used in mathematics in
ordinary speech but we tell the
mathematicians what they're talking
about and that's why when you find it
only for that purpose okay we have no
use of time why because time only
describes in science we explain we have
no use in order to explain something we
have no use for the word time four
seconds four minutes for our if you have
no use words of years we have no use
whatsoever for all that and so these
people have been drilled so much in
college you know with time and equations
using time here and there and when you
say they'll come take all time from
every one of your equations throw in a
trash can we don't need that and so they
say what do you do if
my entire religion away yeah that's what
we're doing here we we don't have any
use whatsoever for time yeah yeah but
what is time time is a comparison of two
motions now move you move by definition
time requires a recording device you
need memory for time and that's another
thing that no mathematician ever
apparently figured out because we don't
have a definition from them of time here
we have a Stephen Hawking he wrote a 200
page book a brief history of time the
only word he has to define his word time
not in the glossary you won't find it
anywhere in that book same with another
fella wrote about time Australian guy
what's his name and escaped my mind
anyways the only definition you won't
find in his books the word time no one
knows what word time means there's a lot
of theories a lot of opinions no one
defines it we need that define if it's
an important word define it otherwise
don't use it very simple so we defined
it we defined it not for us because we
have no use for it we defined it for the
Mathemagician so they know what they
were been talking about for the last
10,000 years okay yeah it's a comparison
of motions and you say well what do you
mean by that let's give it a little
example let me get this thing out of
here
let's say you ask the moon and yeah he
who talks to the moon is known as
lunatic so be aware of that but you're
gonna talk to the moon okay
and you ask the moon you say dear moon
do you move and the moon answers yeah of
course
I move well what do you mean by that
well what do you really mean that you
move what does that mean and so the moon
tells you says well I have location I
have a set of distances with respect to
the earth the Sun Jupiter Andromeda the
whole universe every bit of matter in
the universe there's a distance between
all those every atom to me to to the
moon and at another location I
another set of distances and when we
have two locations we have motion and
that's why I move because here I'm a
dislocation there I'm at that location
different set of distances to all
objects in the universe
uh-huh and how much time does it take
you to go from one location to another
huh yeah yeah I mean how many seconds
how many men how many hours to go from
one location to another I don't know
what you're talking about
what is this thing called Tai see the
moon moves but the moon does not do time
I can tell you a little bit about that I
did time by the three here's the worth
of it but the Moon Moon does not do time
the moon only moves because time you
need an observer someone on the outside
or one of the two things moving has that
be have memory and compare to motions
you have to compare two motions in order
to conceptualize time the moon just
moves itself it doesn't compare itself
against anything all the objects in the
universe move its when man was spawned
by mother nature that time came into
being time started to exist with
conscience and when that if but when
humans go extinct very soon I think well
time will cease to exist so Aristotle
was probably not right when he said huh
it would be illogical to think that time
had a beginning and time had an end and
you do have relativist they say well
yeah time had a beginning and that's
when the Big Bang occurred well though
it was a little more reason it was when
humans specially humans but probably
and earth all before them probably was
aware of the seasons you know you you
have also the Lions you know they have
all these wildebeests they go around in
their migrations and so when they come
back again the line says oh you know
it's it's time again time to go hunting
so they might have a very big notion of
time you know so animals might have
notions of time but you have to have
conscious you have to have comparisons
you have to make some kind of contrast
there to visualize time the moon the
moon removes some Mother Nature doesn't
understand time mother nature
understands motion because all she does
all day long is move celestial objects
around and she makes no comparison she
just said her job is just to move
objects around it's we who make
comparisons we invented time when we
gained consciousness and when we die
time does with us when we're gone the
universe will never had time and will
revert to what it had just motion day so
no time is an invention of humans in
time we'll die with who means humans
because time requires memory and
comparison motion does not move you move
by definition time requires memory ok
and here let me show you a couple things
here you have you go back to ancient
Greece and ancient Rome we had a couple
Ora tours famous ones
one was demosthenes none other where
there was Cicero and here we have them
ok these two gentlemen and so the Mostyn
is on the right asks Cicero on the left
there says hey sis how much time did he
give you the talk over there at the
Senate and so Cicero tells him well we
had this clips to draw and it only
lasted 15 minutes and so that's all I
got to talk until the last drop
into the bucket oh yeah I hear you I had
the same problem you know when I had to
give my speech tells us demosthenes
right and what did they do really what
are we doing here well we're comparing
is the blabbing mouth of a politician I
think they were hated as much as we hate
them today right and we're comparing
that against the drops coming out of the
clap Sidra okay
so we're comparing two motions we're
comparing the motion of the oratory from
Cicero against the drops of water of
falling from the clap syndra okay so
that's a comparison of motions now we
move ahead maybe a few hundred years
forward and we get to the days of Queen
Isabella and Christopher Columbus and so
the Queen asks Oh Chris as a Chris how
long did it take you to get to America
and so Chris says well it took me a
little over two months it took me two
and a half moons what do you mean two
moons well yeah you know the amount of
time it takes for the moon to go around
the Sun that's twice that is what the
time that it took me to go to America
okay so my itinerary matched total in
January one way right took two orbits of
the moon
so what are we comparing well we're
comparing the itinerary of Christopher
Columbus against the trajectory of the
moon we'll compare you two motions
that's what time is and so again you
know what we have here is this notion
that time it's just a comparison of too
much you need you need memory if you do
not retain the memory of another or
visualize or whatever another motion
compared against the motion that you're
going to use as a standard for example
what is the second the sack
this is a portion a very small portion
it used to be at least not anymore but
used to be a very small portion of the
movement of the earth around the Sun and
he chopped that up into months months in
today's days into 24 hours hours into
minutes minutes into seconds that's how
we arrived at the second then they came
with the atomic clocks and with all this
other stuff and now they measure the
second by vibrations of waves okay
that's done differently today but the
standard originally was said you know as
comparison of two motions so if there
was a tick on your watch that went in
your second hand right the second hand
moves one knotch well the earth moved 30
kilometres approximately so again it's a
comparison to motion motion of the hand
on the watch for the clock against the
motion of the earth around the Sun two
motions that's what time is does time
exist well for that you have did you
find a word exists and that's one thing
Aristotle did do we do and time cannot
be exist because in order to exist you
need a physical object time is not a
physical object you cannot say time
exists you cannot say motion exists you
cannot say that love exists not in
science in ordinary speech yet people
bring that working form ordinary seeing
speech says what do you mean we always
say that time exists and that motion
exists love exists and energy is it yeah
in ordinary speech in mathematics in
religion in physics we have to define
the words that's where we have to start
that's what nobody's done okay that's
why we run into these problems and
that's why Aristotle this whole analysis
if you read his whole book of physics it
makes no sense because he's missing the
two words with which he would have made
his case which is object in exist and
with that I will see you what is it on
Sunday if everything goes well we'll
continue with this line of analysis
we'll see you that bye-bye